[Musique]
en quoi elle vous inspire George Sand
son parcours surtout ses idées et
en étant femme c'est à dire en étant une
personne
pas forcément comme les autres à cette
époque elle a réussi à faire vraiment sa
place le premier livre entier que j'ai
lu quand j'étais enfant c'était la
Petite Fadette et ça m'a marqué depuis
30 ans j'avais envie de visiter ce lieu
et vous pensez que c'est important qu'il
y ait des noms de rue qui soit dédiés à
des femmes pourquoi pas autant que dédié
à des hommes elle vous inspire quoi
George Sand beaucoup de respect d'abord
pour le courage qu'elle a eu pour toutes
les femmes parce qu'aujourd'hui on est
le fruit notre liberté et le fruit de
femme de cette de cette trempe
bonjour à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur la route George Sand ici à nos
envies
la grande écrivaine irréalise la majeure
partie de son œuvre 70 romans et 50
oeuvres diverses
né en 1815 à Paris elle a toujours été
attachée au Berry la jeune Amandine
Lucine Aurore Dupin pas son enfant entre
nous hanche et sa grand-mère paternelle
et Paris
en 1832 elle adopte le nom de George
Sand un George sans s prénom féminin
méconnu et Sand comme un clin d'œil à
son âme
à Paris elle fait autant scandale par
ses tenues vestimentaires masculines sa
vie amoureuse que par ses prises de
position en faveur de la liberté des
femmes et contre les préjugés d'une
société misogyne et conservatrice
en 1853 elle s'installe définitivement à
nos envies dans cette maison habitée
d'un incomparable parfum de poésie
laissé par le passage de ses amis Balzac
Chopin de la croix et en d'autres elle
nous quitte ici à la maison de nohavic
en 1876
[Musique]
ici en plein cœur du Berry à Nohan
Vinciane et se linger va nous dévoiler
l'intimité de cette maison de famille et
son domaine qui fut le havre de paix et
d'inspiration de cette femme d'exception
qui a été George Sand
bonjour Vinciane bonjour et merci de
nous accueillir dans le salon de la
maison de Georges Sand et qu'est-ce qui
vous a le plus marqué quand vous avez
découvert la vie l'histoire les écrits
de Georges Sand c'est que c'est une
femme qui a choisi sa vie elle a été
beaucoup critiquée c'est assez violent
ce qu'elle a pu ressentir parfois et
vivre mais ben non elle avait quelque
chose à faire de son destin et elle a
choisi d'être romancière parce que parce
que fallait que ça soit ça ou rien
d'autre je crois je crois que c'était
une question de survie pour elle
d'exister comme ça et ça
bah je sais pas je crois que ça
bouleverse tout le monde donc voilà
forcément on est admiratif ça peut pas
être autrement en me promenant dans le
parc on sent qu'on vient cet endroit
respire la poésie la beauté oui c'est
peut-être un lieu poétique effectivement
mais elle c'est une artiste là mais la
dû ressentir aussi les choses comme avec
vous après c'est l'endroit où elle est
le mieux au monde c'est l'endroit où
elle a grandi c'est l'endroit où elle
est libre voilà on est artiste là pour
de vrai à Paris c'était un peu pour de
faux à Noah c'était un peu pour de vrai
merci beaucoup Vinciane Georges sandais
l'esprit cherche et c'est le cœur qui
trouve et bien j'ai cherché et dans mon
cœur j'ai trouvé pour vous des fleurs
des couleurs du bonheur et pas peur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]